i want to talk today about one tool used
by reactionaries to fool people and to
goad people into reactionary beliefs and
that is the use of the fake and or
imaginary slippery slope
in general reactionaries use fear as a
tool they aggrandize threats beyond what
they are to make people afraid
and then they use that fear to try to
get people to support certain policies
if you're really afraid
of brown people from mexico coming to
commit crimes and take your jobs you're
likely to support extreme policies on
immigration so
the the use of fear
uh and fear-mongering by reactionaries
is very common one example of the false
slippery slope and a slippery slope is
saying well if we do a
it's definitively going to lead to b c d
e f etc when sometimes a will just be a
and a great example we have because of
the pandemic is the fake slippery slope
of vaccine mandates as you may know for
over a year now
the reactionary right has been saying
the first thing is you got to get a
covet vaccine and the next thing you
know
abcdefg
and we now have over 200 years of
history to tell us that vaccine mandates
don't lend themselves to more
authoritarianism and you just look at
the history in 1777
george washington required the smallpox
vaccine for all soldiers
and then you know 30 years went by and
in 1809 massachusetts put in its first
vaccine mandate and then another 40
years went by and then in 1855 a
massachusetts massachusetts instituted
vaccine requirements for schools and
then in 1905 in the u.s supreme court
case jacobson v massachusetts the
supreme court said now municipalities
can just can can put in a vaccine
mandate and people are saying this is
the start of what
and it just never went further in 1977
we had the childhood immunization
initiative start and it's just about
getting kids vaccinated and more
recently people with the covet vaccine
saying this is the start of a dystopian
authority
no and in fact many places have already
removed vaccine mandates for travel
employers are removing vaccine mandates
as the pandemic wanes and so it's an
obviously false slippery slope the
vaccine mandates over the last 200 years
have not led to anything more than that
you can really
tell the the difference in how the right
uses
slippery slopes and fear-mongering by
thinking about something like health
care i mean let's just think it through
we on the left say about health care
listen the right wants this like total
for-profit free market health care thing
they generally speaking want to let
insurance companies charge whatever they
want to people with pre-existing
conditions deny them insurance and if
the right got its way we would continue
to see medical bankruptcies which we're
already seeing we would continue to see
people unable to afford or access care
which we already see all of this stuff
exists right now okay there's no crazy
fear-mongering from the left on health
insurance
the right says if the left gets his way
gets its way it's the start of a
communist takeover of health care where
government bureaucrats will create death
panels and decide whether you live or
die and it will be the start of a
government takeover of every industry
what
so you see how one side does the
slippery slope reactionary
fear-mongering and we say we're going to
continue seeing the same problems if we
don't if we don't fix this very
different language that's used so the
best thing when you start hearing these
slippery slope claims if you do this
it's going to lead to all this other
stuff first of all ask for examples of
when that has happened that's one tool
that you can use
secondly
ask the person claiming the slippery
slope will happen to explain exactly how
because if you actually say to people
well hold on how will a vaccine mandate
on covet vaccines lead to whatever it is
you're afraid of like exactly what are
the steps and who will enact it and it's
also a good tool
to show the disconnect between the
different pieces of the slippery slope
often they won't even explain the path
down the slope
when they do it often makes no sense
whatsoever so those are some tools that
you can use but whenever you're
presented with a slippery slope
ask yourselves those questions is there
historical evidence that that's what
would actually happen
how would it happen and does that
actually make any sense
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our long
time sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite
magic spoon lets you enjoy a sweet
delicious snack without the guilt you
can stick to your goals and still treat
yourself and if you don't love magic
spoon as much as i do they'll give you
all of your money back no questions
asked magic spoon is giving my audience
five dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman